couleur de feu je pense son remercions
Dieu qui n'en a pas en Angleterre
dans l'esprit des hommes les nourritures
a toujours été sacrée les sociétés se
sont organisées autour du repas on mange
pour se nourrir pour connaître et pour
communiquer le langage de la table de
nos hommes le moyen de s'exprimer sur
eux-mêmes et le monde qui les entoure
à la santé des absents ils ont toujours
peur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais toi là s'il te plaît Béatrice je
dois aller au bout de la peau
[Musique]
si
bien vous et bon appétit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le hamburger international est le
symbole de la cuisine fonctionnelle dont
le seul objectif est nourrir vite
à Tokyo à New York à Paris la recette et
la même le goût aussi c'est l'anti
gastronomique
[Musique]
c'est quoi ça c'est le premier
expérience
quand on a ça devant soi
surtout dans le monde
si on veut essayer de comprendre
véritablement ce qui se passe dans le
monde faut pratiquer les approches les
plus les plus intimes du monde alors les
enfants les plus intimes du monde c'est
l'alimentation c'est l'amour c'est la
danse
ce sont les femmes de l'un je crois que
la table la cuisine le cuisinier
ce sont des choses ou des personnes qui
ont un contact très intime avec le monde
en regardant un cuisinier faire en
cuisinant un cuisinier il est possible
d'en apprendre beaucoup
j'apprends la façon dont les hommes ont
décidé de d'attirer à eux le monde le
définir de se définir par rapport au
monde
j'apprends ce qu'on fait du monde et ce
qu'on fait de nous
[Musique]
et on n'en voit on n'envoie rarement on
a clairement l'occasion de manger des
compléments d'ailleurs peu de personnes
madame nous la reconnu mais il a fait de
personnes qui connaissent bien les
copines en bois définitive
le langage des mets est aussi variable
selon l'époque le saumon du siècle
dernier le topinambour de l'occupation
était unique ils sont devenus des
délices de gastronome mais pour en
trouver comment faites-vous si on en
trouve vous les commandez
une très bonne purée c'est très bon
et c'est il est volonté maintenant ou
bien c'est pour vos amis que non
[Musique]
c'était quoi c'était
topinambourrage
en disant c'est Homé fou topinambou en
quelle année est-il
ouvert
bravo
ça c'est la cuisine moderne
c'est la cuisine moderne qui est une
cuisine ancestrale disons que c'est un
engouement nouveau dans la cuisine
française mais c'est une manière de
cuire qui existe depuis des millénaires
qui a des racines bien lointaines
puisque c'est la base de la cuisine
chinoise la cuisine elle a vapeur
et je crois que c'est toi parce que le
pain blanc est mauvais que on le rejette
c'est parce que il y a d'une façon
générale
nostalgie du terroir une nostalgie du
passé la Frédéric et on la retrouve non
seulement dans le fait que le pain noir
est devenu le pince-noble
c'est des mots en réalité ce qui se
passe c'est que pendant très longtemps
toute personne qui mangeait était relié
avec la terre qui l'entourait le
vigneron a été retiré
au goût d'une certaine terre au bout de
sa vie qu'il connaissait ils connaissait
le goût de ses poireaux ils connaissait
le goût de son boeuf chacun connaissait
le goût des choses et aspire elle monde
qui était autour de lui à travers des
goûts qui connaissaient et puis tout
d'un coup à travers le monde dans lequel
on est maintenant il n'y a plus cette
communication on mange des choses qui
ont été dénaturées alors
la nostalgie de terroir qu'utilise des
fois les publicités c'est uniquement de
faire de de nouveaux gens la nostalgie
de vous réelles des choses c'est même
pas du passé mais du présent
[Musique]
[Rires]
beaucoup d'analogie
[Musique]
pour le plus petit
alors là c'est la sauce
[Musique]
oui c'est ça
mais il y a une oreille qui
[Musique]
on fait l'entrée en matière
vous faire plaisir
[Musique]
d'ailleurs je connais le nom du cru ça
s'appelle le clou des Boudou
et le clowns au Clos Saint-Georges qui
danse nous au village
voilà
lui c'est lui l'âge Saint Georges chez
nous le premier cru du vilain ah oui et
en Bourgogne presque tous les grands
crus sont en deuxième position à la
suite du village pour donner nous à la
cité
et là vous avez le Clos des bouleaux
[Musique]
ça c'est pas toujours facile alors
Monsieur Loyau
si nous nous contentons si nous nous
contentons de parler
d'échanger des arguments nous
communiquerons qu'avec des mots et nous
communiquerons pas avec la vérité mais
si nous partageons le 20 le pain et le
sel nous communiquons à un niveau
non-verbal qui renforce largement et se
substitue largement à notre
communication verbale je veux dire à la
limite que autour d'une table nous
pourrons communiquer sans dire des
choses sérieuses car notre authenticité
les tailleurs
ensemble on dit quoi il faut qu'on aille
au cinéma
ce qui fait que des gens qui ont des
barrières qui les séparent peuvent
communiquer
mais pourquoi c'est quand même besoin
de dire on va tout révolutionner voici
ce que Frédéric lange dit du repas
d'affaires les hommes réunis autour
d'une table plongée dans le même monde
et le consommant sont naturellement
égaux et unis et à exceptionnel dont
chacun ressent la gravité certains
allant même jusqu'à s'engager devant les
autres à accomplir ultérieurement des
actions magnifiques
c'est pas possible de faire un test
de votre travail
aujourd'hui encore c'est bien souvent à
la fin de repas entre la poire et le
fromage qu'un contrat est signé mais
invité c'est aussi faire sentir la
différence entre soi et les autres et
cela avec d'autant plus de force que le
repas doit être en un moment où la
hiérarchie sociale s'estompe
exceptionnellement comme pendant les
guerres à table les hommes sont les
soldats du monde qu'ils assaillent et
consomment
on arrive à des impossibilités de
traitement malgré la multi programmation
malgré tout ce qu'on peut imaginer parce
que il y a des traitements journaliers
systématiques qui peuvent la machine
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
merci
en premier
le repas entre copain dont les
itinéraires se croisent est une
nécessité pour les solitaires de la
route ils recréer un confort de courte
durée le steak pomme frite et le ragoût
évoque les traditions familiales
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au milieu là
[Musique]
[Rires]
le matin
[Musique]
on est des clodos
le repas des clochards a lui aussi Siri
et on y crête aussi quelques fois des
affaires
[Musique]
pour moi c'est déjà la joie de me
retrouver avec mes amis on peut se dire
des choses entre amis qu'on ne peut pas
se dire entre couple déjà ça c'est très
important il y a une intimité qui se
crée entre nous et peut-être une vérité
aussi il n'y a pas de
on n'est pas sophistiqué entre nous on a
on ne parle pas vis-à-vis de notre
partenaire on est naturel on a le droit
d'avoir le cheveux en biais voilà vous
arrivez démaquiller
un bon vin sans avoir l'air d'être
ridicule par nos partenaires un petit
peu votre mari vous dit pas ah tu tiens
mal c'est pas tout à fait oui au
contraire ça nous rendait ça nous rend
fantastique parce que ça nous rend
nature les hommes les hommes vis-à-vis
des femmes et du vert font preuve d'une
misogynie sert totale mais totale
voir la semaine passée je déjeunais avec
un monsieur ce monsieur ne connaissant
pas les vins me demande de choisir le
vin je choisis un vin et je choisis
l'année et le sommelier apporte le vin
le début ne le décompte pas je lui dirai
la prochaine fois et féminin d'en servir
dans le verre du monsieur c'est moi qui
commande éleva il le monsieur dit non
c'est madame qui goûte le vin je goûte
le vin que je vais choisir
il me dit dans ton très hautain il est
bien je dis non je le trouve pas bien du
tout et il me fait mais c'est ce que
vous avez choisi madame et à ce
moment-là je lui ai dit parce qu'il
avait une serviette autour de la
bouteille je dis est-ce que je pourrais
voir l'étiquette et puis j'avais choisi
à 66 et c'était à 67
elle est très forte et c'est vrai
un repas d'homme dans un des grands
restaurants de New York
bon français
bonjour
de feu je pense qu'on remercions Dieu
qui n'en n'ont pas en Angleterre
la cuisine nouvelle fait sans cesse des
trouvailles par exemple le canard au
couat
ok parce qu'il y a cette acidité
c'est lourd et là il y a et je disais à
mes chêne c'est c'est le combiné de la
base de la cuisine chinoise c'est ce
weekend ça ouais c'est ce mélange de ce
mélange
c'est formidable
qu'est-ce que le boucherie
dans cette position ce sont les
premières secousses qui vont faire ces
branler les choses ce sont les toutes
premières secousses il y en aura de
beaucoup plus grand mais on voit que la
société entière est en train de changer
au fait qu'elle change ces manières de
tard la table c'est un effet un point de
repère sociologique ontologie
philosophique religieux à partir de quoi
se se termine les personnes se
définissent les personnes dans la
relation qu'elles entretiennent avec les
autres dans la relation des entretiens
avec le monde c'est à partir de la table
que l'homme se définit par rapport à la
femme se définit par rapport au canard
qui va manger ce défi par rapport aux
vins qui va boire se définit par rapport
au monde qui fait venir en Satan qu'il
s'agisse dans le monde social ou du
monde alimentaire
qui ne se juge lui-même qu'il définit se
définit ce juge se définit assurément
alors si la table change dans ces
manières dans ce qu'elle supporte dans
ce qu'elle attire ça veut dire que la
civilisation change ça veut dire en
d'autres termes que l'Occident
abandonne peu à peu un archétype ancien
qui est vulcien la table sur lequel il
se construisit c'est sur la table de se
déconstruit l'Occident judo-chrétien
c'est sur une table que Jéhovah croix de
voir mettre devoir écrire ses lois qui
transvait un Moïse c'est sur une table
que le Christ demande à être consommé
c'est sur une table qu'on apprend le
monde à l'élève à qui on donne un
pupitre c'est sur une table des matières
c'est sur une table d'orientation c'est
avec une table de multiplication qu'on
apprend le monde aux enfants cette table
là change ce qui vient dans l'assiette a
changé la manière de venir à table à
changer la manière de servir la table à
changer ça veut dire que notre société
est en train de se chercher un nouvel
archétype il n'y a pas de d'archétypes
pour l'instant qui ne soit capable de
remplacer la table est en train de s'en
inventer un autre maintenant le meilleur
temps intervenir 50 2
ici oui
vous êtes quand même pas obligé
qui a gagné
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour
tu vas plus rien avec ça
[Musique]
il faut parler d'une détérioration du
repas il s'agit-il même d'un repas se
nourrir debout se nourrir vite se
nourrir dans le tumulte ne pas penser au
goût de ce qu'on absorbe se nourrir pour
survivre se brûler avec un petit café
qui a poli le temps quels sont les
conséquences de la vie
urbaine des distances de l'extension du
travail féminin c'est dans le monde
moderne une des manières les plus
banales de ce nouveau
[Musique]
et il arrête la personne qu'elle avait
réduit en disant un principe assez vite
et l'autre lui demande mais pourquoi et
dans un qui répond mais pour qu'on en
parle
[Musique]
c'est la vitesse 25 minutes de moyenne
par repas qui fait contracter dans
l'espace et le temps le rituel du repas
comme ses messes en un quart d'heure que
vous l'écurie pressé
[Musique]
oh là là
toutes les étapes sont respectées les
grands classiques sont là du steak
frites à la pêche melba les enfants les
animaux font de la fête la voiture
dévore la route la route engloutie la
gastronomie
[Musique]
le savoir et la saveur ont la même
racine
la gastronomie et dans tous les cas
le goût qu'on ressent les saveurs qu'on
ressent et vous font connaître un
certain nombre de choses vous donnent un
certain nombre de savoir vers ce vin et
portable une certaine saveur donc
c'est-à-dire de sa partie de savoir
cette eau est porteur d'une certaine
d'un certain type de savoir le repas
c'est l'organisation des saveurs donc la
réalisation des savoirs il m'intéresse
moi de savoir ce que j'apprends je
constate que ce savoir là a été
complètement
minorée complètement dévalué par rapport
à l'autre savoir qu'on apprend par les
oreilles et par les yeux qui est le
savoir qu'on apprend à l'école mais il
m'intéresse de savoir quel est ce savoir
qu'on apprend sur la table à manger
parce que je trouve que votre
vocabulaire monte de primarité
il n'y a pas de il n'y a pas de
vocabulaire pour le goût qui est quelque
chose d'excessivement qui va à l'instant
et à la matière de l'individu beaucoup
plus que la réflexion ou si le goût
arabe appartient à réflexion il n'est
plus goût et le choix je reste au niveau
du goût
et c'est pour ça que je suis très gêné
archétype d'ailleurs
marin pêcheur en rupture de poisson et
ça se ressemble un peu et moi je suis
ému par exemple qualité de cuisine et
l'émotion arrive comme peut arriver
avant d'ouest ce qu'il faut de primaire
et avec toute l'intensité des choses
primaires de merveilleux de séduisant
d'existence rien à voir avec il n'y a
pas intervention de jugement il n'y a
pas d'intervention il n'y a pas analyse
il n'y a pas référence il y a seulement
plaisir parce qu'elle est en matière
quelque chose de tactile et je suis très
gêné
je suis souvent ennuyé parce que je vous
entends
discerner alambiquée analysé dissocier
dichotomiser pour envoyer un terme à la
mode alors que moi je me commande de
prendre le renifler de sentir et je
pense d'une de base le plus importantes
et le plus profonde de la puissance et
je jouis
l'homme primaire qui goûte de l'homme
secondaire qui regarderait l'homme qui
coûte en fait il est très intéressant de
goûter
son goût il est possible de brancher sa
pensée sur sa bouche et de faire que la
pensée éprouve du plaisir autant que la
bouche il y a pas que l'homme primaire
qui connaît le vent à l'ouest il est
possible de connaître le vent de la tête
ce que Michel Tournier avait appelé
appel devant barracle en étant soi-même
observateur de ce du plaisir qu'on
ressent non ce n'est pas parce qu'on
observe parce qu'on s'observe en temps
de prendre du plaisir qu'on perd ce
plaisir on peut avoir deux plaisirs le
plaisir immédiat le plaisir c'est bon
vous permet de cuisiner ce qui a déjà
été cuisiné donc n'en ressortir avec un
plaisir d'équiper en quelque sorte voilà
c'est tout et je crois par exemple les
hommes de l'état de Vinci goutte le vin
une fois avec la bouche et une deuxième
fois toujours avec la bouche on le
parlant le vocabulaire d'état de 20 est
aussi
subtile variées sensuelle que le vin
qu'ils agent
il est frappant en couleur
[Applaudissements]
il est très spirituel
[Musique]
c'est de la grande musique déjà
c'est pas de l'opéra mais
c'est quand même de l'Opéra Comique de
grande classe
on pourrait faire une belle
fable et encore mieux une belle chanson
avec ce monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]